what do taxis playing-cards love hotels
and Gameboys have income at one point
they were all a Nintendo venture these
products are among the mega hits and
mega flops in Nintendo's 130 year
history whenever the end was near they
bounced back with an innovative company
saving product and their secret to
modern success great games with classic
characters this is how Nintendo
periodically turned reports of its
eminent demise into Nintendo meme from
2010 to 2015
Nintendo was in trouble its most recent
major console the Wii U was considered a
flop next to its rivals profits were
tumbling and its stock price was near a
low or still some analysts saw the
surging popularity of mobile smartphone
games as a major threat to Nintendo's
cash cap it's portable gaming systems
another major blow came in July 2015 the
death of the company's president Satoru
Iwata
but then Nintendo's fortunes suddenly
reversed in late 2016 it released a
mobile smartphone game the wildly
popular Super Mario run and capitalized
on fan nostalgia with the limited
edition NES classic then in March 2017
the company released the long-awaited
Nintendo switch which became an instant
hit so it's just a very sleek and nicely
designed and pleasing Hardware to have
in your hands but that's that it really
comes down to the games and they had an
incredibly strong lineup of games from
the start with the help of these
reimagined classics Nintendo sold more
than 20 million units in the first two
years and it's now become the fastest
selling console in US history they have
this kind of disney-like ability to
introduce their characters in one format
and
now maybe your interest in their
products fades away a little bit and
then years later they'll reintroduce
those same characters again with the new
product the switch was hardly the first
time Nintendo had putted successfully to
a new type of entertainment Nintendo
began in Kyoto in 1889 with hand-painted
playing cards called Hana Fuda or flower
cards because western-style playing
cards were banned Japanese gangsters
call Yakuza favored these in their
illegal gambling parlors and Nintendo
made a killer campaign they made every
kind of playing card imaginable until
1963 dubbed Nintendo's experimental
years during this time they did
everything from food taxis love hotels
before circling back to toys there was
even a self-made extending arm called
the ultra hand the love tester ultra
machine and even a laser clay shooting
system that would later morphed into NES
classic duck hunt the success of some of
these toys cemented their place as a toy
maker leading them into the game use
nintendo only started developing home
game consoles about 35 years ago with
the introduction of the Famicom in Japan
a Nintendo Entertainment System in the
u.s. their timing however couldn't have
been worse the gaming industry was
crashing there were too many consoles
and too many terrible third-party games
but Nintendo succeeded where others
didn't they bundled a hit game called
Super Mario Brothers created by
visionary game designer Shigeru Miyamoto
to date this game has sold over 40
million copies worldwide holding the
record for a full 18 years Miyamoto who
joined Nintendo in 1977 who go on to
design other hits like Zelda Mario Kart
and starfox idak making game is so much
that that I do it for fee and each new
gaming console over the next few decades
had the key hit games to go with it the
game boy had Tetris and Kirby's
Dreamland the Super Nintendo had Super
Mario World and
Donkey Kong Country and the n64 had
Mario Kart Goldeneye and Zelda Ocarina
of Time they've now have people like you
and me who grew up playing with you no
games with Mario and Link in the case of
Zelda it's pleasing to pass along those
characters to your own children but they
had their fair share of flops as well
like the Virtual Boy a headset that
allowed the user to play games in
virtual reality the Gamecube was also
less than successful
and while 2018 was the best year in over
a decade the forecast is once again not
so positive in September of 2018 more
than a decade after rival Sony Microsoft
Nintendo debuted its first online
subscription service but the reviews
haven't been great
gamers complain that Nintendo's platform
lacks must-have features like in game
chat
they say it's susceptible to cheating
and get frustrated with its connectivity
issues they seem to manage whether it
was the Wii or Game Boy or the switch
most recently they do seem to come back
just when people have written them off
and they do seem to always come up with
these new things to push things forward
so it'll be interesting to see how they
react to this shift to online
multiplayer games they'll probably come
up with something new in that arena too
if you give them enough time after all
it wouldn't be the first time Nintendo
reinvented itself
you